[Musique]
la vie si tu kankan est astucieux bell
bell
johnny
c'est aussi le plus sérieux à jouer et
le migou devenu un ami
comme ça dont je veux c'est vrai ça tout
blanc quand tu avais mon bec
oui les beaux jeux les biens briquet
alors les jambes on m'a fait pleurer
fraîche ta fleur est magnifique
oui on alors on peut commencer et belle
au social on t'a dit bonjour et ben
bonjour à tous et bon jour également et
bonjour ou et maintenant obama en voyage
le jeu de la géographie voilà l'affairé
fait nous partons pour quel pays
vasella carte qui va faire découvrir
d'abord la carte géographique du pays
pour avoir le musée y aura le drapeau
s'il ne trouve pas alors à temps voilà
la carto c'est un grand pays européen
sow samba oui oui oui oui là la capitale
est là elle est basse ah oui elle est
parlée la wii ah oui il ya le point
alors on a bien le coin là oui oui c'est
pas de la salle anono non non non non
mais je me pose une question on verra
tout à l'heure là nous avons à bari nous
avons le drapeau est important ça me
parait fait si oui il est très
particulier ce drapeau vous voyez ici et
c'est du verre
le losange et jaune et au centre vous
avez alors disons le c'est une chute un
globe terrestre
il est il est bleu il est plus puis à
quelque chose d' inscrire ici au milieu
comment dire bonjour dans la langue du
pays ah ouais
comment ça se prononce à bandia ce
vendredi à samedi à ce bon ben dhia
liasses ça on le dit si on rencontre
quelqu'un on est tout seul ça serait
bien du lait alors à mon avis et je
pense que vous avez tous trouvé il
s'agit d'un des plus grands pays du
monde par sa surface et aussi par sa
population
c'est le brésil le brésil est une petite
chose qui me chiffonne là parce que la
capitale qui semble être au bord de la
mer ici doit être l'ancienne capitale à
rio de janeiro
car aujourd'hui la capitale du brésil
est à l'intérieur des terres très
nettement c'est une nouvelle capitale
qui s'appelle brasilia
breizh avait sa c5 et bones días et du
portugais et en portugais puisque la
langue par le brésil et le portugais
voilà bon bah je pense que vous avez
bien je vous avais réussi et je sens que
tu veut m'envoyer dans le jardin oui moi
je ne me suis pas trompé et oui alors je
me précipite dans le jardin tu es quand
même bien obéissants maintenant et c'est
vrai je suis dressé
ah oui la voix alors oui oui j'arrive
bien vu que j'arrivais street joue long
à venir nous rejoindre il faut cesser le
temps quand même
alors vous êtes le point commun le
week-end dont ils appliquent alors attia
appelle le voilà voilà voilà voilà voilà
voilà j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive au
j'arrive j'arrive
alors j'y vais européens allaient en
place remplaçant haha tu es tout seul
aux battues oui pourquoi je pense qu'il
est inutile de rappeler ce qu'est le
point comme non nous savons que nous
cherchons quel est le point commun entre
vous tous les trois les rôles que vous
allez jouer bon excusez moi oui j'ai
arrive encore et toujours la cote qui ne
faut pas du tout fait tu permets que
nous jouions en qu'ils mangent rkc
s'cusez moi
pouvez-vous m'indiquer où je pourrais
trouver une laitue et bien au fond à
droite du jardin rapido il ya un certain
nombre de l'étude tu devrais trouver ton
affaire mais laisse le jouer pour
l'instant nous allons écouter tout comme
corse
or voilà qu'il se revoit alors tout cas
encore aujourd'hui
alors bon le point commun alors tu sais
ce que je suis aujourd'hui mois nous
justement je te demande parce qu'un
parisien
j'occupe à paris une situation
exceptionnelle et alors je vous assure
que je ne passe pas inaperçu tous les
touristes viennent me voir il n'y a pas
beaucoup de faits à paris qui se passe
loin de moi j'en ai vu défiler à pied à
cheval en voiture
mais attention jeu je suis très bien
placé
gilles une bonne taille mais alors je ne
suis pas du tout la tour eiffel at voilà
c'est tout par contre moi je suis très
très grandes lignes en grande que vous
avez du mal à imaginer ma taille et je
vous comprends bien quand vous voyez
tout petit mais c'est parce que je suis
très loin de vous je suis même si loin
de vous que vous ne viendrez jamais me
rendre visite quand je dis vous me voyez
je devrais dire vous nous voyez car j'ai
énormément de soeurs elles sont si
nombreuses je ne sais pas du tout
combien il y en a et vous non plus vous
ne le savez pas à une dernière
indication
je n'aime pas la lumière du jour non
pendant le jour je me cache et j'attends
la nuit pour me montrer autrement dit en
anglais je suis une star
oui oui ça va bien rapide les bruits on
va bien exclusif ou smooth tuez moi je
suis là bas moi que chez moi à moi vous
m'avez certainement vu si vous êtes
promenés un jour au bord de la mer c'est
sur le sable et vous êtes posé beaucoup
de questions sur moi d'abord vous avez
trouvé que j'étais très joli et puis
vous vous êtes demandé si j'étais bien
vivant vous m'avez touchés vous m'avez
retourner ce que je n'aime pas
d'ailleurs je n'aime pas du tout ça pas
du tout et comme vous avez vu que je ne
bougeais pas ben vous avez imaginé que
j'étais une sorte de plantes et là
permettez moi de vous le dire vous vous
êtes trompés évidemment je peux pas
marcher bien vite mais avec mes cinq
pattes
j'arrive tout de même à me déplacer
voilà j'espère que tu as trouvé un oui
au début j'ai eu des problèmes mais
maintenant je crois que ça va beaucoup
mieux bon alors je suppose que vous êtes
comme moi vous avez découvert que tout
cancan parlais tout à l'heure de
la place de l'étoile n'est ce pas à
paris qui s'appelle d'ailleurs
maintenant la place charles de gaulle
etc voilà est parfaitement la place des
étoiles donc à paris je pense que bell
bell c'était tout simplement une étoile
l'ancienne rivale et oui c'est vrai et
pousse moussu un animal avec cinq pattes
il s'agit de l'étoile de mer et oui mais
toi le maire s'était donc les toiles qui
veut réunissait tous les trois et ben
voila j'ai gagné il encore terrible ce
rapide aux jetons croyais la bri je vais
te préparer une petite surprise musicale
j'arrive je t'attends à tout je vous
fais une visite tous bons fabrice pouces
moussu oui oui c'est à nous maintenant
c'est exact
on va jouer ensemble oui vivement tu
peux avoir vos crayons tu vas au tableau
les jeux l'est j'y vais oui ah oui tu
peux y aller tu es sûr oui oui tu veux
qu'elle me promets que tu ne feras pas
de fautes d'orthographe ou non là j'ai
bien étudié cette semaine c'est une
promesse que tu aura bien du mal à tenir
en respect j'espère espère alors cette
semaine a comme la semaine dernière
d'ailleurs à un mot en au fait tu te
souviens bah oui hein on note l'aide
neuf le prix
on commence par quel être un ses os et
c'est bien oui ah ouais nous fait à
temps j'avais tracé les petits traits
d'un set de 3 4 5 6 et 7 et est la
dernière un but lui
voilà très bien bon alors maintenant je
t'écoute
bon alors une plante aller non s'il aura
une place une fleur c'est pas une fleur
un arbre non plus attendons alors c'est
un animal ça c'est un animal qui adore
les animaux tout genre mais oui moi
j'adore les animaux alors c'est un petit
animal ou non aux du trail synchro un
gros un gros gros gros
gros gros gouye 1 paraît gros c'est un
animal qui vit en afrique
oh non non non je suis dans la savane
dans l'âge on au no no no no je vais
t'aider y vit dans l'eau à évident loup
dans l'eau un très gros un très gros
alors je peux aider si tu veux je te
donne la troisième lettre
oui alors la troisième lettre c'est un
c1 c'est oui à caa1 gros dans l'eau en
un gros gros gros énorme lee normes lui
tu plaisantes là je plaisante je
plaisante
parce que je verrai bien le début mai
alors la fin ça va pas du tout comment
cela parce que tu penses à un cachalot
exactement un cachalot très forte ici
alors toi tu es fort et tu écris gâche à
l'eau bah j'ai écrit cachalots oui mais
comment la commande passée à huy chrh
parce qu'il est dans l'eau elle a eu
exactement à cachalot il est dans l'eau
alors elle a eu beau vre pousse donc
j'ai encore fait une faute d'orthographe
c'est hallucinant ca c h rares kasha oui
l'ol aux tcl ôté et on bat reçues qui
n'a rien à voir avec le mot en question
cachalot voilà comment ça servait à
cachalots qu'est ce que tu veux faire je
suis déçu et pas deviner à quoi fondu
avec lotois ya une chose que tu n'aurais
pas pu deviner non plus je vais te dire
c'est que le cachalot
c'est une grosse baleine mais avec une
différence
les baleines n'ont pas de dents alors
que le cachalot il en a ces quatre fois
bien des très très grosse à elles ont
plus de 20 cm de long et elle pèse
quelquefois trois kilos
tu te rends compte trois kilos jolie
bête ah ben je voudrais pas être mordu
par un cachalot moi par exemple sa
marque il aurait bien du mal à te
trouver le cachalot web
ils ont la forêt se remet bien quand
même bon bah bravo tout de même pouces
mossu pour ses explications tout con
quand on était très très intéressant ça
m'intéressait on va chercher pour la
semaine prochaine aurait cherché un
autre mot en australie peut aller voir
bébé oui nous regardons réel belle et
musicale la fabrique des jouets avec moi
[Musique]
ces écoutes moi mon cher
nous oui mais aujourd'hui j'avais encore
de faire jeudi cas à bon on part tout
s'est alors si nous balorre un cadeau un
cadeau alors tu places le dos oui nous
allons faire un voyage en mer j'espère
que tu n'as pas peur de te retrouver
tout entouré de badauds dos voilà c'est
exactement ça y est je vais t'emmener
sur un bateau un vrai avec des vals peu
misérable petit rap
pourquoi baradeau exactement
voilà tous les marins étaient très
contents ils s'entendaient très bien
c'était tous des arts comme deux des
accrocs oui c'était pas des ennemis
s'était déjà qu'on a des amis oui les
amis c'est elle at il acheté alors à
bord il y avait un capitaine avec une
belle fête à bout de temps plus doux à
baba doré et si je suppose que ces
denrées une veste à boutons dorés pour
la et est alors écoute moi bien parce
que c'est une très belle histoire le
bateau est parti très loin sur la
méditerranée ils ont navigué longtemps
il travaillait dur toute la journée et
la nuit il n'avait pas beaucoup de temps
pour faire dodo bongo et douches des
toits doit passer les bus de battre une
petite seconde parce que je suis
débordée par la dodo bon et puis un beau
jour il leur est arrivé une histoire
très ennuyeuse
il était en mer depuis longtemps depuis
je ne sais pas peut-être 4,5 ou semaines
oui
oui qu'à trouver un nom tu me dé 4,5 ce
matin quatre semaines a aussi semaine
six semaines voilà de l'histoire elle
est très triste oh non je ne veux pas te
la raconter
alors maintenant regarde les notes que
tu viennes placé basics étaient tous
vêtus
mais ces pics enroulé qui fait de lui le
très doué moi je voudrais aussi a pas de
réponse et au bouquet qui se finit à
enfin la dodge dodo do i do ré do do si
oui alors tous les chante maintenant
qu'est ce que c'est alors alors
ce sont des cdd n'avaient
[Musique]
et caetera et caetera et caetera toi et
regarde ses traits sa petite ou non
et ben voilà pic en bouche tu vois c'est
pas mal bossé vous devez jouer battant
les tranquilles du trafic ont tenté
contre les peuples à la vie majed s'est
désisté léger choc se déchausse les
comme jenny bas dominent war livre on a
fait attention les gars me santi dénia
ça me semble heureux car il aime à b
le bien soit pas malade
son charme
[Musique]
aujourd'hui et vouloir devenir familier
e
[Musique]